if you are deeper than listen up black
Buffalo is the only tobacco alternative
that will give you the same experience
as traditional smokeless products just
without a tobacco leaf or the stem I
honestly I stopped two months ago I've
been on the black Buffalo train I've
been hitting a heart I'm a mid guy I got
peach in my hand but I'm a mint guy you
can use promo code answer at black
Buffalo comm for 25% off your initial
purchase get it right now what's up I'm
Andrew Schultz I'm going to answer the
internet would you jerk off LeBron for
all of his athletic ability yeah who
wouldn't jerk off from Tron for all of
his athletic ability
100% I'd suck his dick now I wouldn't
suck his dick that's not true I wouldn't
suck his dick no I wouldn't do it I
wouldn't do it I wouldn't do it
I've definitely jerk him off would you
kill baby Hitler if it had to be in a
very gruesome way no I can't kill a kid
man yeah I kill his dad or like kills
mom I go back one more generation cuz
they had to [ __ ] him off right they had
to do something to make him Hitler so
that's all it's their fault too so yeah
I'd like kill their parents in a
gruesome way yeah if you could only have
knees or elbows what would you pick so I
have to walk like Lieutenant Dan or
elbows 100 salvos yeah because you can't
eat eat like a [ __ ] horse no dude no
way 100% I think I'd be fine walking
around like this how often do you bend
your knees dad it's like a little
penguin 100% come if as long as the
stairs were wide enough I could get
upstairs
absolutely yeah you don't really need
after 30 you don't need knees so elbows
I would want if you could wipe one group
of people off the earth what would it be
does it have to be people or can we do
animals what group of people off of the
earth
no no I know I know I'm obviously not
gonna pick a race throw away my career
for a [ __ ] free box of asker the
Internet no um fat chicks with short
hair that's died yeah that jigs with
with short hair that's died like pink
and I wouldn't wipe them off the earth I
just take away their their fingers so
they couldn't tweet and just make the
internet a beautiful place again and
then as far as animals go I think we can
get rid of most animals most of them I
think they're useless yeah most animals
gotta go how much money would it take
for you to strangle a puppy I'm not
doing it and dogs are there's like three
animals I'm okay with cows dogs and
chicken yeah I think but dogs are fine
dogs are fine they're good animals yeah
they're fine
we've like I just don't need the money
that much that's my honest answer about
I just don't need them us to strangle
the puppy it wouldn't sit with me I
could kill a puppy easily but it's just
like I don't want to I have to remove
the puppies like to clean it up I'm
weird I like to earn it I'm weird I'm
it's yeah it's got to be so I gotta like
save somebody else like strangled
puppies saved my mom yes
trying to probably saved my like family
my brother no I mean like you die or
something bad happens to you yeah she
had probably strangle a puppy dude
but then I'd [ __ ] make you pay for it
dude it would be bad I would remind you
every single day of the dog that had to
die for you it would be your hand
picture that dog's face every day I
would get I would make you tattoo the
dog's neck onto your hands so that you
have to look at like what you were
responsible for every time you wash your
face
it's just fur it would be the fur of the
neck like hand
prints on fur would be all your your
palms yeah who would be the world's most
dominant one-on-one basketball player if
everyone was forced to play naked John
Salley John Salley just swinging that
grandfather clock of a dick dude that
guy would be by far the greatest let me
tell you hand checking would be back in
yeah immediately the only reason
handshaking is illegal is because they
work clothes the second they get naked
is like well maybe we should would you
rather sleep with a sexy [ __ ] or a
below-average regular chick
I mean I'd get the [ __ ] from the miz'
for obvious reasons right just to see
her [ __ ] struggle to hold that thing
but and because they move so quick
they're like scurry I've never seen them
if you're seeing that move no no dude
it's like they're scurry or like have
you ever seen one put on a backpack
dude this is because the backpacks
already so close to their back like it's
on the ground yeah dude it's like when
you put a blanket on a knight right it's
just and I'm covered and so I think that
it would be so quick but as far as like
you know any sexual attraction to the to
the [ __ ] I'm you know no offense but
I'm not I'm not big into it you guys
make great reality shows though I'd be
fine if you just pan back and there's a
million midgets blowing me right now
it's just completely out of this job
would you rather spend the rest of your
life blind or inside an Olive Garden
well that's a good one the rest of your
life is in the Olive Garden
I've never been in an Olive Garden but I
could I mean it's just be a great I can
have sure everything can come to me it's
like being like we're like when you're
like a cartel boss in jail this is like
cartel boss in jail all the food that
you want inside the Olive Garden hands
down are you kidding be blind why would
you want to be blind because you can't
see anything anyway you're basically in
the Olive Garden but then you get to see
everything that's brought to you
would you rather be the best looking to
the world or be able to read minds
I wouldn't want either because being
able to read minds is horrible you just
like think about all the awful [ __ ] like
do you like going on people's Twitter
that's reading minds
right like Twitter is awful it's like
why are you sharing us what do most
people think all day I'm hungry I'm
sleepy I'm tired I feel fat I think you
want to read that
like dude Professor X the reason he's in
a wheelchair it's because he's probably
tried to kill himself a million times
he's reading people's mind just jumping
off of bridges he's just going to
isolated places trying to kill himself
he probably moved that [ __ ] coin
himself or whatever they're gonna see a
movie which made it you see please put
it right here dude magneto please
anything yeah I don't want either if
there was stats available for every
aspect of your life what one stat would
you want to see how many times I've
given myself a butt rash by just
scratching my ass my own app like helmet
dude all the time dude all the time like
I'll just scratch through the underwear
like and I only give it to the left
cheek for whatever reason I don't
scratch the right cheek by the left hand
right cheek I kind of scratched from
hole 2 up on the cheek and I won't know
how many times I've given my own self
chafing how many times I chafed myself
that's the stat that I want to know
thousand thousand minimum Mik dude
thousand minimum okay I'm working on
some like light scabbing now I
let that come down the second it comes
down we're going raw rip it raw
what are the best starburst flavors it's
just pink and everything else like this
is pink and then everything else yeah
it's shocking that they don't just make
it all pink no no but they yeah I
purchase all pink ones matter of fact I
was like so I go to st. Burning Man I'm
sure you guys heard of and like you're
supposed to bring like a gift for people
that you meet you have a cool
conversation with and I just brought
pink starburst only who's the worst
group of fans honestly the worst group
fans are like the worst group of fans
are any woke group because they're not
your fan they just agree with you and
the second that you shift off-course
even slightly they'll be there to cancel
you because that is their bread and
butter so those are the worst group then
so there's a lot of people out there
like even in my industry they think they
have fans because they're like serving a
market and the second they shift they
don't even realize this the second they
shift all those people are gonna eat you
alive
so those are the worst group of fans the
wokes would you rather have sex with
your dream girl once or get nudes from
every girl you know sex with dream girl
ones do you guys like nudes Emma there's
three naked people on the Internet yeah
but you didn't earn it but they have to
do it but you know she's give another
move nude saw their guys and the nude
she's giving you were the ones from the
other guy I don't even like back when I
was asking for nude I wouldn't even ask
for what she's wearing now I was like
going to the vault and gave me the
[ __ ] hits like let me know where this
goes like I know it's [ __ ] March
you're not in your best shape neither am
i but give me July until I want July I
want Hamptons you haven't eaten for a
week you try to bang this Wall Street
guy give me that [ __ ] the picture of the
pool in the back of the house he rented
hi guys there's been answer the internet
peace
you